We had heard about a virus.
One of us had heard about it.
We supported each other,
and it ended up testing positive.
And at that time they said 25% of people
seemed to be only getting
sick with this virus.
So do what you do to
live your life healthy,
be good, come back and
see us again in a while.
- Which shows that the lifestyle of some
male homosexuals has
triggered an epidemic,
of a rare form of cancer.
- I went back about nine months later
and they said that only 25%
of people were surviving.
Meaning that everyone was dying.
Which later evolved the next year into
100% of people were dying,
there was nobody that
was surviving the virus.
- [TV Newscaster] The condition severely
weakens the body's
ability to fight disease.
Researchers are now studying blood
and other samples from the victims,
trying to learn what
is causing the disease.
So far they have had no luck.
- Hi, I'm Keith.
And I've been HIV positive since 1985.
So I'm one of those,
one of those survivors.
I'm leaning up against a building
where I'm about to go in and
get a Sculptra treatment.
Sculptra is something
I've done several times
over the years, which has
helped with facial wasting,
which is a result of medications from HIV.
Hi!
- [Robert] I'm Dr. Robert Cohen.
Today we're working at Being Alive!
Which is a HIV/AIDS social service agency.
We've set up a program called
the facial reconstruction program.
Earlier medications that were
used to treat HIV and AIDS
caused fat loss.
They would cause fat
lipo-trophy, or lipodystrophy.
Which manifests itself as a hollowness.
Primarily in the mid-face area,
in the temples, down low.
People get that as they get older.
But with the HIV patient
population it was a more acute,
and it's a more severe
form of facial wasting.
(music)
- [Keith] You know you're
living with a virus inside you,
a lot of your friends die,
you've survived this thing,
and then it starts to appear on your face.
It starts to show.
And all of a sudden you look in the mirror
and you're seeing the
actual disease itself.
At the time, I was acting and modeling.
My agent, I remember, he
called me and he said,
you just got a call from
a casting director who wanted to know,
like, what's up with Keith?
He's not looking like he usually looks.
Is he sick, is something going on?
And that kind of started the end of like,
really the end of my career.
- [Robert] What we've done,
we've put white cream,
and it's a numbing cream.
The numbing cream takes
about 10, 15 minutes to work.
It will numb up topically.
I need to get the product into his face,
so for the first couple of injections,
it helps make it more
comfortable for the patient.
- It became kind of a terminal
death sentence automatically,
and there's no medications for it,
there's nothing to treat it,
and your own government
has turned its back on you,
because it made it a gay disease.
It just sucked, because
we were having to prove
that we were of value to
live in the first place.
And the doctors had no cures
and there was no leads on anything.
And people were just dying left and right.
You were choosing which funeral
you had to go to on the weekend,
because you had to make a priority
of which person was more important to you.
- [Robert] This product
is called Sculptra.
It's what's called the biologic filler.
It's a chemical that will stimulate
the body's natural production of collagen.
We're going to inject the patients
in the area that he, or she, needs.
And the patient will
wait for about a month,
and they'll start to
see the collagen grow.
And their face will be...
The volume lost will be
replaced with collagen.
It lasts about one to two years.
- [Keith] I wasn't able to get a job.
I was having these symptoms.
It came to being alive.
Literally just put my arms out,
stretched them straight out,
and I just started sobbing.
And I said somebody's got to help me.
And that's all I said.
They just put their arms
around me, on both sides,
and just took me into the back,
just basically, just helping me with
whatever I needed and one
those ended up being Sculptra.
Man, oh, get in here!
- Well thank you for coming and joining us
and letting me stick sharp
objects into your face.
It always makes my day better.
(laughing)
- HIV is now what's called a
chronic maintenance disease.
The patients now will continue to live
a long and healthy life,
a long and productive life.
It is a disease and it
can change your life.
There's always hope.
Whether it's HIV, whether it's diabetes,
whether it's depression, there's hope.
Take your medication,
talk to your doctors,
and most importantly,
surround yourself with people.
Whether they have the same disease entity,
or something else, and reach
your hand out and help them.
Nothing feels better than
helping somebody else.
And that's what we're here for.
We're on the boat together,
let's help each other row.
(uplifting music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel!
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here!
- That was my part.